[Music]
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new norm
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
not citizens you are terrible at this
your negative attitude is not helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
knuckles you are really bad at punching
[Music]
i'm the bad man have been for a long
time
that's three people likely killed with
the same weapon what's that round them
on the floor you shoot us losing his
mind
anything else i can do for you the room
number again it's on the key holder
the retainer for your services is 10
million dollars
no
very carefully the girl stays alive
you're answerable to me
a 13 year old and relocated to a group
home was not here last night
yes what's wrong you're sure
hugo thinks it's a pro settling scores
trafficking vincent sierra i can't keep
doing your job for you who is this
you're too slow to make the bay what
they did to children they're not doing
anything about it
he's taking out the traffickers that we
couldn't
he's interfering with an international
investigation
you said he wasn't going to be a problem
i've done crazy things
why don't you and i just have a talk i
know you're not well no time for that
if i'm dead you'll never know the truth
stand down
i want to believe that you're a good man
vincent
if i can't finish this you have to
but they have to be punished
which side of this do you really want to
be on
i want justice
we all have to die what's important is
what you do before you go
oatmeal latte light foam
hey
how's uh the mars boyfriend long
distance dating sucks how long have you
guys been together eight years eight
years how did you manage that he checks
all the boxes oh you mean literally
strong jaw mental fortitude six-pack
we had a plan and then he got his
martian dream job
so i enrolled in the mars program
you ever worry the wrong person is
headed to the wrong planet goodbye
forever walt
five
four three
two
one guys
hello hey
what are you doing here who sneaks onto
spaceships i can explain
ever since i was a kid i dreamt of going
to mars
you can keep my dream alive come with me
you cannot under any circumstances leave
my room okay
this is gonna suck isn't it only for 35
days
you have to keep a low profile
[Music]
all right you guys i'm your captain this
is sophie my girlfriend long-term
girlfriend i don't remember you from
orientation
what happened
you have to come right back and just rip
his jumpsuit off
hey what's up i just miss you sorry do
we have a call scheduled
come on let's go have some fun i don't
do fun you also don't fly on rockets or
conspire with stowaways sophie for
watching
100 bucks since you just said that in
your wrist
just gotta face it you're a space
criminal now
historic journey to make life more
meaningful
now that is a story people want to hear
you've spent your entire life trying to
check an impossible set of boxes
i can't risk the plan when you find that
thing that you're willing to cross the
entire universe to be with
make sure it's ready to do the same for
you
[Music]
it doesn't matter how far you travel you
can never escape yourself did you just
come up with that
no [ __ ] that is a very common phrase
[Music]
what's the worry here nick you've lost
some of your talent as an actor
no
what did he say he says he loves you but
he went in a different direction
i'm done
i'm quitting acting tell the trades it
was a tremendous
honor to be a part of storytelling and
myth-making
[ __ ] man i'm driving through the hills
i'm sorry one more time
we got another offer it's a million
bucks it's to attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party i would never
do that it's the easiest gig ever you
play yourself what do we know about this
guy anyway is he into something strange
it's not like he's gonna want you to
suck his dick or [ __ ] his wife or watch
you watch him [ __ ] his wife i wouldn't
think so
welcome to majorca mr cage the guy that
owns this house what's his name cubby is
harvey gonna want me to uh
play him cubby
nic cage
god this place is stunning what is your
favorite movie that's one of those
questions that's impossible to answer
you can't just limit it to one imagine
me and you i do
is it too much
is this supposed to be me
it's protest
i'll give you twenty thousand four
[Music]
i'm in position i think that's the actor
nick cage nick h i love you
have you seen close to i'm 44 years old
why the [ __ ] would i see croods too i've
seen face-off and con air
you guys we're with central intelligence
do you know who you're spending time
with one of the most ruthless men on the
face of this planet i need you to help
the us government
[Music]
find a way into that room
i
nick
see myself doing more of this stuff i
think i might have a real gift for it
good because we got another mission for
you no no no no no no
your friend is working for the us
government don't lie to me
are those my golden guns they're my
golden guns i don't want to kill you
you're the last person i want to kill i
love you i love you
cage
[Music]
i am known by many names
[Music]
whisper
i am [ __ ] boot holy freakolos
you launch me
[Music]
and the rest of you play double time
hey
hey you want to see something cool
gracias you've been great get home
safely good night
you're still here okay okay one more
number i call this one the legend will
never die
[Music]
i have bad news you died
[Music]
doctor
relax i am [ __ ] booze i have night life
and how many times have you died already
uh
i am not really a math guy
honestly
do you like aspartame
does this have shellfish in it
a cat always lands on his feet what
[Music]
what's happening
watch
and then there was the giant today so
what is that like uh
a four
that makes eight puss what do you wish
to do with your last life when you only
have one life that's what makes it
special
drive pedro
fear me if you dare
goldilocks and the three bears crying
family
you're supposed to be dead
it never fails whenever i team up with
you things go wrong trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you killed that cute no
and with the paws it's all so
cute
am i doing it
stop you're gonna give yourself a
harness
why are you the only man who wants to
stay with me
i don't know
thank you too
i do
why is mom so different around other
people i think this is who she is
[Applause]
you love me
of course
[Music]
the fact that she's comfortable floating
all these relationships around all of us
you're better than it
she's different
that's what i like about her
i just want to feel joy in my life
[Music]
you want to tell me why you didn't come
home last night not really
this isn't a game melinda
it's always been a game
[Music]
[Applause]
the truth is
if you were married to anyone else
you'd be so bored
if you kill yourself
[Applause]
do you think we'll ever be just happy
yeah i hope so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
no
if we don't stop it
always with the spinning shaker you
brilliant man you know me pal i can't
pass up a good poor kid
to save our world each of us has a role
to play
if by tea time all of us are still alive
we should consider our efforts a success
thank you
correct three points to hufflepuff
he's not here for you he's here for me
i drew my wand which was even more
foreign
[Music]
so
you are a dog
i am the batman
i'm not really great with animals yeah
i'm not really great with people
probably because of my traumatic
puppyhood as the child my family was
taken from me as a puppy i was taken
from my family so i steal myself my
emotions always check no one ever
getting past my impenetrable defenses
[Music]
ah what the heck
that can't be sanitary
every day me and suits hang out
you literally worship the ground that
dude walks on technically he flies
batman works alone except for robin and
alfred commissioner gordon my i.t crew
whoever morgan freeman played what do i
have here squeezy bruce
squeezy what
that better be a licensed toy or i will
freak out
hi
there's a gun
this is the quiet car
can't use your small inside voice in
here son there's a gun
[Music]
[Music]
talk to me i am ready you are getting
the new and improved me
because if you put peace out in the
world do you get peace back
i think you might be forgetting what you
do for a living
take the gun every job i do somebody
dies i'm not that guy anymore
some conflicts require a gun
[Music]
hey this is nice
okay what am i snatching and or grabbing
a briefcase he said you want it simple
for your first job back it doesn't get
simpler
dude i don't even know you
there's nothing simple about this job
something else going on here
yeah i'm not the only one on this train
looking for this case
evan
where's the briefcase oh it's not [ __ ]
[Music]
it was trusty
we are right on settle everything that's
ever happened to you this is gonna sting
this let you hear
fate
that's a [ __ ] deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no thank you you know what do you
have uh anything sparkling
that's the one thank you domorigato
i'm sure you don't want to talk this out
no particularly
okay
[Music]
exclusively in movie theaters
[Music]
yes
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
but the cure
it's curse
i have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost now a place of choice
to hunt
and consume blood
or die
we all have monsters within us
it's up to us to control it
what if i can't
michael morbius
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to be
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
more bs
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
a new marvel legend arrives exclusively
in movie theaters april first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
you